من فضلك ارفع يدك
اليمنى وكرر ورائي أنا
كامالا ديفي هاريس أقوم بالتأرجح رسميًا
أنا كامالا ديفي هاريسون
سأدعم و أدافع عن دستور
الولايات المتحدة الذي سأدعمه وأدافع
عنه ضد
كل الأعداء الأجانب والمحليين ضد
كل الأعداء
المولودين  والمحلية التي سأحمل
الإيمان
والولاء الحقيقيين لنفس الشيء الذي
سأحمل الإيمان والولاء الحقيقيين لنفس الشيء
الذي أتحمل فيه هذا الالتزام بحرية
بأنني أتحمل هذا الالتزام بحرية دون
أي تحفظ عقلي
أو غرض تهرب دون أي
تحفظ
أو غرض عقلي  من المراوغة التي سأقوم
بها
بأمانة وبصحة جيدة وأقوم
بأداء واجبات المكتب
الذي أنا على وشك الدخول فيه بأمانة وإخلاص إلى واجبات
المكتب الذي أنا على وشك الدخول فيه ، لذا
ساعدني الله ، لذا ساعدني
[تصفيق]
[تصفيق] يا
إلهي
[تصفيق]